welcome to this video hi the killer
queen from the UK that's a new opponent
right now in our played in before check
okay okay we transpose to an Enzo after
all g3 III you are normally they go g3
him and trying to make use of the
fianchetto and that sets an uncommon
move hmm okay I know you don't want to
start spend lots of time even here after
the capture i'm going to play 96 yeah
come on give me the bishop pair or not
I mean this pre-move entered really
funny is this such a big decision okay
he gave me the bishop l96 on yeah
impossible there are multiple ways to go
here maybe here getting from some
pressure directly on default cannot take
the pawn yet because of my before Bishop
liability
ok check
yeah maybe just be six continuing to
develop with Bishop d7 maybe Bishop a6
could also be can also be an idea okay
is playing very ambitious Liam okay
let's go d 6 this fits into the position
anyway I guess
yeah so what to do I can take on before
play a five-night to be form yeah let's
let's try to be a bit quick IM rly it's
getting very tiring to lose positions
that you never lose just because you
have spent some time I need to make some
good moves so maybe play play mediocre
moose if I do them a bit play them a bit
quicker
yeah it looks active enough the NOI diem
let's see i can get the bishop to be
seven and then rook c8 possibly and he's
not very well developed which is not
really hindering him from moving the
night again okay so how to do this 97
assess the idea of the slim hmm
Eric g8 looks very slow maybe maybe I
need to do it ok I can still play Bishop
e7 next I'm the queen g5 just
threatening thou whoopsie eight is not
really doing me anything great yeah
maybe get this get the threaten
nah probably g3
okay is that some way to get to get to
the king here a queen f5 Queen you for
something I never get on a light square
start with this may be a book d5 can be
an idea sometime rook g5 rookie five
Queenie for TOS has roughly five Quincy
seven
and just green before there's always
Bishop f3 okay
John prawn you must move this right
yeah I shouldn't forget that I have
their pond so an end game might be might
be quite quite okay maybe just maybe I
can exchange greens IAM would be quite
okay they probably must move the Queen
somewhere e 7 trading wouldn't be
wouldn't be good but Quincy 7s 9 a-6 so
I probably okay if I take now and then
f6 why not
just send the night back at least i'm
not down on the clock
probably I want to prove on to make sure
that you for is not coming
hmm and it's not so helpful
yeah I mean I'm better with the a porn
but am i winning hmm questionable rupee
8b to mighty will lose on China reversed
roles like 5x kya hai b8 be too i don't
know how he should prevent that it's
it's winning it's minus 1.8 or something
by the comp yeah he absolutely must
avoid the Queen trait I mean he has
active pieces the night on e5 and the
Queen but after the Queen trade it gets
it gets immediately immediately good
here I can take it so night Essex wasn't
even possible yeah he definitely must
link the Queen and to keep the Queen's
on after that I'm immediately I'm
immediately for choice here with day
upon yeah this is basically coming to
this he he must keep the Queen's Own if
he allows the Queen trade I'm
immediately clear d better and this is
what happened in the game yeah you for
that's always after the bishop retreat
there is DS DT ad for hanging and here
you're the default don't even need for
as possible anymore so this is this is
really quite quite clearly quite clearly
better for black here you can defend
better with this I try to use the king
but he can block here this is very tough
still 22 win maybe not possible to
windward I can try okay thanks for
watching